un hombre japonés intentó inmolarse
cerca de la oficina del Primer Ministro
este miércoles después de ser trasladado
al hospital declaró a la policía que se
oponía a los funerales de estado de
previstos para el 27 de septiembre el
costo del evento llegaría alrededor de
12 millones de dólares con la
participación de más de 50 jefes de
estado una controversia en tiempos de
alta inflación global según las últimas
encuestas el 56% de la población de esa
prueba la decisión
realmente buena y mucha gente se
sintiera cómoda celebrando el funeral de
estado y sintiera que lo merece Entonces
sería una historia diferente pero esa no
es la realidad en absoluto si nos
fijamos solo en la economía ha sido la
de ave un éxito sin suave fue asesinado
el 8 de julio pasó nueve años en el
poder fue calificado de Ultra
nacionalista y sus mandatos estuvieron
marcados por varios escándalos
financieros pero sobre todo es su
supuesta relación con la secta religiosa
Moon lo que indigna a la gente
especialmente a los líderes religiosos
como líderes religiosos sentimos un gran
peligro de que el gobierno esté
obligando a la gente a expresar sus
condolencias por eso Hemos emitido una
declaración pidiendo el apoyo de la
gente
la secta mum está acusada de
manipulación presiones financieras y
colusiones políticas de hecho el
presunto asesino hubiera matado al ex
Primer Ministro como una manifestación
contra la secta varios ministros
actuales han reconocido tener vínculos
con ella algo que la opinión pública
considera inaceptable